ال8:00 صباحا درجه الحراره وسط لندن قرابه
السادسه تحت الصفر لكن هذا لم يمنع هؤلاء
الممرضين والممرضات المطربين عن العمل من
الوقوف لتسجيل اعتراضهم على موقف الحكومه
من مطالبهم موقف تراه نقابه التمريض
متغطرسه
يدخلونني الى غرفه ويقولون انه يمكنني
التحدث عن اي شيء الا الاجور
عرضت الحكومه زياده اجور طواقم التمريض
بنحو اربعه في المئه وقد زادت بالفعل اجور
قطاع الصحه كله العام الماضي بنحو ثلاثه
في المئه ارقام يراها المطربون هزيله في
زمن فاق فيه معدل التضخم احد عشر في المئه
ويقولون ان مطلبهم بزياده تبلغ 19% سببه
ان اجورهم لم تجد بشكل مناسب خلال عشر
سنوات
اخرى قال الاضراب مئات المستشفيات في عموم
بريطانيا باستثناء اسكتلندا التي الغي
الاضراب فيها بعد اتفاق الحكومه والنقابه
على معده لزياده الاجور ويوضح الممرضون ان
مطالبهم لا تقتصر على الاجور
الخلاف مستمر اذا حتى شعار اخر وكذلك
تستمر معاناه المتضررين من المرضى
الممرضين تزامنا مع احتجاجات اجتماعيه
عديده اخرى ومع انذارات باضرابات من قبل
السكك الحديديه وفئه اجتماعيه ومهنيه اخرى
ويبدو انها جنته هذه الاضطرابات مع اقتراب
اعياد الميلاد ستؤثر على حياه البريطانيين
وتثير تساؤلات بشان التفاوض بين حكومه
المحافظين والنقابات اسد الله الصاوي
الجزيره لندن